jetzt aber möchte ich erstmal mit einem
der journalisten sprechen die den
us-präsidenten sehr nahe begleiten
dürfen er gehört nämlich zum kreis der
white house korrespondenten und das ist
mein kollege vom politiker daniel
lippmann daniel wer regiert eigentlich
amerika wenn der präsident ausfällt also
da ist zunächst der vizepräsident
natürlich wenn der präsident also
handlungsunfähig ist und nicht mehr als
präsident arbeiten kann dann kann der
vize präsident mike pence entscheidung
treffen
lindburg betonte manager carsten fritsch
wurde das kabinett kann ihm die
regierungsverantwortung vorübergehend
übertragen oder jump selbst kann seine
autorität mike hanks vorübergehend
übertragen wenn er sich ans abgang führt
aber an diesem punkt sind wir derzeit ja
noch nicht angekommen
man denkt ja immer der präsident wird
ganz besonders geschützt wie konnte das
denn überhaupt passieren
[Musik]
das ist meiner meinung nach ziemlich
einfach das weiße haus hat einfach nicht
angemessene vorsichtsmaßnahmen getroffen
um den präsidenten wirklich zu schützen
nehmen wir halbwegs also eine der
engsten beraterin von donald trump sie
war ganz offenbar ja unvorsichtig beim
schutz des präsidenten also es gibt da
eine ernsthafte sorge dass sich noch
weitere personen angesteckt haben
könnten
der präsident und sein stab sie wollten
das virus so lange wie möglich runter
spielen weil sie der wirtschaft nicht
schaden wollen
das hätte bei james wiederwahl geholfen
aber das ging jetzt ordentlich nach
hinten los und wir haben einen
präsidenten mit corona obwohl er den
secret service hat obwohl er über
atomwaffen verfügt er kann das virus
eben bekommen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren